New York now the hardest-hit state in
the nation with more than 20,000
confirmed cases of the corona virus and
more than 13,000 of them in New York
City alone the National Guard now being
deployed to build makeshift hospitals
amid this surge here with an update is
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio
America morning to you thank you very
much for joining us we saw the president
the president tweeted out this morning
this he said the world market for face
masks and ventilators is crazy we are
helping the states to get equipment it
is not that easy just got 400
ventilators for mayor de Blasio work
beginning on four hospitals in New York
millions of different items coming
that's your question isn't it when are
the things going to get there
that's exactly right Steve you know look
I've spoken to the president and I
appreciate that he understands just how
crucial it is to get those ventilators
New York City that is the difference
between someone who's suffering in one
of our hospitals who might make it if
they have an access to a ventilator but
if we can't have them on the ventilator
the right time we could lose a lot of
lives who otherwise could pull through
and I do appreciate that the president's
team is focused on that it we're gonna
need a lot our estimate is approximately
15,000 before this is over because of
the sheer growth pattern you mentioned
this thing is moving rapidly and I think
April is gonna be a lot worse than March
and I fear that may may even be worse
than April and that's just New York City
it's then going to be happening more and
more in other parts of the country as
well and so I Steve I have to emphasize
our hospitals in a matter of days or
weeks depending on the hospital are
going to be stressed to the point but
they cannot provide the kind of health
care we're used to unless we can get
them a huge resupply of equipment
supplies personnel and our hospitals
bluntly are going to start to go broke
and that's why all partisanship aside
what's being talked about now in the
stimulus bill is crucial direct support
for public and private hospitals because
if they cannot
the bills and this is true all over the
country if they can't pay the bills
health care will decline rapidly overall
not just about coronavirus overall this
is the thing I'm focused on we got to
shore up our hospitals quick well
particularly in New York City mayor
because I heard dr. Brooks last night in
that two hour long press conference with
the president say that New York City the
rate of attack is one in a thousand
which is jaw-dropping
that New York has five times the rate of
infection over other parts of the
country and so you've you've got this
problem you just mentioned that you
think that April and May are going to be
really bad for New York City so you in
addition to the National Guard you're
thinking maybe this should involve a
larger portion of our federal military
right that's right Steve look I think
the United States military is a force
unlike any in the world in terms of its
ability to organize mobilize do
logistics move material all over the
country and they happen to have some of
the finest medical personnel anywhere
right now
the epicenter is New York City but we
see it happening more and more in other
parts of the country you're starting to
see Florida Louisiana Georgia all sorts
of states are going to go through there
wave next the only force I think that
can keep up with the need to constantly
move supplies and equipment where
they're needed and doctors nurses other
medical personnel where they're needed
is going to be the US military National
Guard's are great within each state but
I think we are seeing these dominoes
start to fall ste this is a national
crisis the only parallel I think is not
only the 1918 Spanish influenza but the
Great Depression itself in terms of the
sheer national impact into people's
lives and I think we have to recognize
if the military is mobilized quickly
they actually could set up a structure
to make sure supplies go where they're
needed first then they could be
transferred to the next state and
greatest need the next state the the
doctors and nurses could be moved around
but there's no other force in America
that could possibly
do that besides our military right I
know that Peter Navarro is now the point
person from the administration that you
deal with on it on a daily basis and
that's great because you know we want
all the supplies that are needed by the
various cities to get them as quickly as
possible but you New York is a unique
situation because you've got so many
people on that island and in the five
boroughs I mean in Manhattan I think
it's you've got 28,000 people per square
mile are you thinking about any other
restrictions on people you know in the
days ahead just so that they have a
social distance of six feet or something
else just to keep it from spreading yes
Steve it's a great question the first
thing I want to say is a very
appreciative that a president Trump
named Peter Navarro to follow up because
he's been doing an amazing job I spoke
to him many times yesterday he's all
over it and I'm very thankful for that
in terms of the question you asked I
want to emphasize that the spread
pattern even though sure it gets more
intense in a big urban area like this I
don't think anybody in this country
should rest assured that there's not
going to spread in every part of the
country it's just a nature of the virus
and I think people have to understand
this is not about blue states red states
the coasts or the heartland
unfortunately it's here in all 50 states
and the smart thing we can do is get
ahead of it so to your question look in
this city we have the finest police
force anywhere in the world and
Commissioner Dermot Shea said just
yesterday you know they're going to go
out and do what they do so well show
people the right way to do things
communicate with the folks of this city
and say you got to keep that distance
now Steve if you're a family you live
under the same roof social distancing is
a different reality because you're
already in that deep contact if you're
going out to the park families are
staying close together that's fine but
for other people anyone who is not from
the same exact family unit the same you
know people live under the same roof
we're gonna keep that six feet apart
rule we're not gonna allow any
gatherings I'm a guy who loves sports
but we're not unfortunately even be able
to allow team sports we have to keep
people separated so
our men and women of the NYPD will be
out there spreading the message telling
people break it up if they have to break
it up move along no lines tight together
at a grocery store no grocery stores
full up if we do this right and I think
people are getting it Steven really do I
think they're hearing the message and
the media has played a very important
role here helping people understand just
how serious this is
I think we see more and more and our
Police Commissioner said it he's been
all over the city last few days he said
he's so impressed at the number of
people are following the rules and I
think this week even more since we now
are officially in this pause in New York
State life is going to be very different
but if we do this all over the country
we can actually slow this thing down and
keep our hospitals running and that's
the other thing I want to say Steve
people have to understand if we don't
knock this thing down our health care
system cannot handle this strain if it
comes on too fast and that's just not
not just for folks with coronavirus
that's for all the other health care
challenges all the folks with cancer and
heart disease we have to protect
everyone in danger by keeping our
hospitals going and that means that
social distancing is the key to slow in
this thing down absolutely and New York
City is of course as we've been talking
the epicenter of it right now here in
the United States Mayor DeBlasio thank
you very much we know you get your hands
full please come back to update us on
what you're getting what you're needing
and how the city of New York is coping
thank you Steve